doux et fondant quand il est frais
certains lui trouvent des arômes de
champignons et de sousbois quand il
prend une jolie teinte bleutée le
crerotin de Chavignol doit son nom à un
petit village du Cher et il se fabrique
toujours au cœur du sanscerrois région
de vigne et de
chèvre à la ferme de Saint-Louis papa
fait toujours du vin pas mal du tout
d'ailleurs maman a longtemps fait les
fromages et c'est aujourd'hui Amélie
leur fille qui a repris
l'exploitation un peu de céréales de
vignes quelques cochons et 120 chèvres
que nous allons apprendre à connaître
par leur
prénom là on a Auckland par exemple
puisque celles qui sont nées en 2019
c'était des des noms de ville ou de
capitale celles qui sont nées cette
année on nom de président de la
République ah donc Valérie et ben on
pourra je pourrais te présenter
Valérie René voilà j'ai même dans le
coup ça a étendu ma culture générale
parce qu'il avait tout un tas j'en ai
quand même 20 23 et je ne connaissais
pas 23 prénoms président de la
République mais j'en ai trouvé 23 quand
même alors 5e République 4e République
on est remonté un peu plus
loin des noms de présidents ou encore de
personnages de dessin animés il faut
dire que ces chèvres sont un peu les
stars du crotin artisanal qui est
produit
ici pour l'appellation Chavignol la la
race de chèvre c'est la l'Alpine
chamoisé donc qui a une chèvre brune
avec l'AR dorsal noire elles font 3 L de
lait par jour et sachant que pour faire
un Chavignol il faut presque 750 ml de
lait donc donc avec 120 chèvres oui je
fais des fromages mais pas non plus des
contes industriels et puis cell qui me
donne le rit c'estàdire que si elles
vont bien derrière moi le la ferme elle
ira bien donc j'essaie vraiment de
m'adapter à elle en fait c'est pas moi
qui commande c'est c'est elle qui
commande j'ai 120
[Musique]
patronnes de novembre à avril les
chèvres qui n'aiment ni la pluie ni le
froid reste à l'abri le reste du temps
elle pèse en plein air les chèvres elles
sont là pour me donner leur lait pour
que je puisse faire des fromages mais
dans ma gestion de mon troupeau j'essaie
d'aller un peu au-delà de ça
c'est-à-dire que je suis pas à regarder
bah toi tiens tu fais un peu moins de
lait hop tu dégages donc si jamais j'en
ai une qui est plus liuse qui va savoir
me les ramener si jamais voilà quand il
faut rentrer qui va prendre la tête du
troupeau même si elle me fait un peu
moins de lait bah elle est importante
parce que elle a aussi ce rôle un peu de
chef de troupeau et ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que ça se
retrouve sur les petite chevrette
souvent tu un tempérament qui se
retrouve de mère en fille j'ai des chefs
qui vont de 1 an à 8 ou 9 ans soit elles
peuvent continuer à faire des chevux et
donc elles reste dans le cycle vraiment
voilà on fait on fait un Chevreux on
repart en lactation et cetera soit elles
peuvent plus en général je les passe en
longue lactation c'està dire que je
continue de les tirer et quand elles ont
plus de lait ben je les garde dans un
j'ai un petit enclot exprès et puis ell
finissent leur carrière gentiment
là ce qui est hyper satisfaisant en fait
c'est que tu as tes chèvres tu fais
pousser des céréales pour les nourrir
grâce à ça elle te donne du bon lait et
ce lait que t'as tiré tuen fait du
fromage et les gens le trouvent bon ça
c'est mon bonheur il est là quoi et
aussi quand mes enfants me disent qu'il
est bon quandme ça c'est c'est encore là
c'est la 5e étoile tu vois